hey christina good to see you you too
and i am happy to say that i absolutely
loved the last season because
a terrible liar so i am really glad that
i can say that with absolutely
i'm also happy you could say that oh my
god i was an absolute mess by the end of
the final scene of the last episode
so
i i'm curious i mean you knew this was
gonna be the last season but when did
you know
that this was the story of how these
characters would come to an end i mean
were you always like if we get to season
four we're gonna do a musical and we're
gonna go to the future i mean how
when did that happen
well
no we i we never really got to plan the
whole thing out i mean that's the way it
kind of works with a netflix show is you
put it out and then you find out if we
come back and so there was never an
opportunity to do a master plan so when
i when we found out that it was going to
be the last season
to me it was like the first thought it's
like well this thing that we've always
wanted to do in an episode
like that feels like kind of the peak
version of dear white people because
it's like it's such a hyper reality we
have these really real issues but we
find a way in that is it's entertaining
and exciting and different that's what a
musical does
we should just make the whole season a
musical and that's really kind of as
much as i knew in that moment
and then and then sort of the other part
of me the nerd part of me my favorite
finale of all time is um
the series finale of star trek next
generation
uh it was actually one of the first
things we played for i played for the
writers room uh and in that season
finale we meet the characters
in the future the present and the past
and why that is so powerful is that for
a show that was really episodic and they
they also didn't have the ability to
plan the whole thing at once
at the last up you know for them it was
the last episode for us as the last
season um it sort of gives you a sense
of the whole thing up until this point
but it also like takes it to a new place
and kind of leaves everything on the
floor which is what a musical is
supposed to do
so
those are the ideas i came in with plus
a lot of like emotional trauma per usual
that we sort of
mixed the ideas with the emotional
trauma that justin was stealing and came
up with this season i mean you know
that's sort of the recipe it's been
each season and this season was no
different in that way
do both of you have favorite musical
performance numbers in this because i
have to say they were all just
amazing oh yeah thank you i'm so glad
that it connected because
i mean for me my favorite musical number
is for sh well
i would say for sure but there's so many
good ones but i'm really partial to uh
marquee's virtual insanity in episode
five i also think it's
one of the most beautifully
shot
uh
justin uh oh right i did that sorry you
did that that was beautifully shot most
beautifully edited i i love
everything about that number so much i i
just and marquis like trained with the
granddaughter of the gregory brothers
for six months to like learn how to tap
well enough to do that which
is incredible so yeah i would say that's
probably my favorite but
with so many second places that i can't
even begin to
yeah it's hard there's a lot of kids on
this one that i love dearly i bye bye
bye was so refreshing because this was
you know sam bailey who both wrote and
directed that episode um
had this obsession with the song that
was just so funny and specific to her
and it didn't i'll be honest it didn't
even fully make sense to me at first um
well so many great things in the show
begin with me being like y'all i don't
know and i walk to my office and then it
like sits for a while i'm like oh my god
we have to do it and so um
sam really got to see that all the way
through this song that sort of starts
off as a symbol of you know how frankly
white sam white has become with her
white boyfriend but then to use it as
like a breakup song it was just
brilliant and the way she filmed it was
exciting
you know we didn't just sort of go for
songs that we liked but we also went for
like kind like musical number types that
we liked and she really took on this
surreal
rock opera music as dialogue style
yeah it was so
unexpected and fun and but i have a lot
of shout out for that and for all of
them but chris bowers and his team
the orchestrations on these songs
especially like the reinvention songs
like bye bye
are incredible the first time we heard
the like
this rant
pearl jam sounding
bye-bye it was like what is this i love
it
justin you're you're moving on to some
pretty big properties and i'm curious
for you i mean did you have a list of
dream projects that included
working in the star wars universe and
telling a story inspired by a disneyland
theme park ride like what like how does
that even happen what does it feel like
to be you right now
i'll be i'll be honest um every day is a
joy
uh it's uh
you know what's funny at a certain point
i i learned to let go of my list
because if i was just sticking to my
list there's a lot of things i wouldn't
have gotten to do including the two
things that you mentioned um both which
came
as a surprise they were one of many
things that i was just working like hell
to get
and um
you know anyone in this industry will
tell you you really have to sort of try
and make 45 pies to get a pie made and
so
uh you know it was just a lot of work
and those are the things that happened
versus the things that just totally fell
apart are still in progress um but i
have to say like it's really exciting
but it's also like it feels really good
that everything i've been doing up to
this point is exactly what i needed to
do to be ready for this stuff um it is
hard in all of the ways in all the same
ways the challenges really are the same
they just apply at different scales and
you know with different problems to
solve um so i i it feels good i feel
really comfortable
i'd be lying if i said it was easy or
like always fun but
you know making a musical during covid
making a musical during covid definitely
uh i think probably helped uh justin and
i
uh prepare for different scales of
challenge because calamity yeah
yeah i mean jaclyn i like it i love that
you're going to be a part of bringing
back cordless vote because it was such a
huge series and now people are so
excited about seeing it again
why do you think it's an important story
to revisit
oh my goodness i think it's
well it it's
part of it is and look i love i have so
much love for the showtime american
version of queers folk but i am a
die-hard british
version russell t davies aiden gillen
charlie hunnam like that show was so
punk rock and
like queer aggression in this way that's
really
refreshing and just like unapologetic
and i think we
stephen dunn and i are definitely
leaning more towards that tone
and
to be honest the every version of the
shadows point is like very white very
cis
gay
um and our version is not it's set in
new orleans it's
um what you know has one of the leads is
a trans woman
it's many people of color i think we
have like one
white person in the main cast and and
it's ryan o'connell who's disabled and
also beautiful and talented and funny
but
you know and finn argues we have a
couple white people but um it's just
it's really wonderful to get to tell
queer stories um honestly i truly want
to do
for queer stories what we've been doing
on dear white people for black stories
and queer stories which is like
not create a show that is is
bearing the full burden of
representation but instead is creating a
story that's about queer people in all
of their messiness um in the same way
that coco is not every black woman sam
is not every black woman joel's not
every black woman instead we get to tell
stories about three four five different
kinds of black women
and i feel like in a weird way that ends
up
playing that messiness ends up making
the show more representative than if you
to be honest if a show was just made by
like a cis white dude like it just ends
up being like a very flat version of
like this is an acceptable black person
that won't let won't get me canceled
like nobody's gonna be mad at me for
this one
it's more fun to tell stories about us
where we get to like
go deep and be messy
well i love this show i love this last
season i love everything you've managed
to do with the show and the fact you
made me actually like bye bye bye
and
justin i am so thrilled that you are
taking on my favorite ride at disneyland
so
thank both of you for talking to me very
much
thank you so much thank you i hope we
get to talk about it soon
absolutely thank you so much